turning now to mardi gras today is fat
tuesday in new orleans where the crowds
and celebrations have returned as
coveted concerns ease the city's
traditions and culinary scene continue
to evolve and reflect its many many
cultures and for our series the dish
jamie wax discovered the growing
influence and popularity of vietnamese
flavors in classic louisiana food
[Music]
you won't find what is arguably the most
sought after carnival pastry in new
orleans in the city's bustling tourist
areas
you'll find it here tucked away between
strip malls and trailer parks along a
highway in new orleans east
on a dreary saturday morning you came in
from two and a half hours away in
lafayette yes to get this king cake on a
saturday morning to get this can kick on
a saturday morning
more than a hundred people lined up to
buy king cake at this unassuming
vietnamese bakery
dong
has become a crescent city institution
in past years
king cake isn't the only attraction here
we have a bunch of different i was going
to say po boys
as we learn from nene nguyen a former
top chef competitor and respected chef
who is from new orleans she showed us
some of her favorite menu items buying
these with our vietnamese french bread
which is very similar to the po boy
bread here and you can even see how
crackling it looks is the vietnamese
baking tradition
going back to traditional french as well
yeah i mean when the french came they
brought us bread they bought us puff
pastry so this is pate so which sounds
really french already they caramelize
and they braise pork and onions and
black pepper and then they stuff that
into these flaky puff pastries that's
one of the best things i've ever eaten
dongfong is just one example of how the
local vietnamese community is
influencing louisiana cuisine starting
with the ingredients
veggie co-op a small farm run by
vietnamese immigrants initially catered
just to local residents they are
starting to grow more vietnamese-centric
ingredients for restaurants here
some of that produce like greens and
herbs are on the menu at margie's grill
this is not a vietnamese owned
restaurant but it is sort of a fusion
restaurant of southeast asian and
southern traditional countries what
really drew such a large population of
vietnamese immigrants to
louisiana specifically i could only
speak for really my family the seafood
industry is huge here vietnam is such a
coastal country that is like the work
that people knew how to do my
grandmother shucked oysters my uncles
made crab traps
my dad and his family deep sea fish my
grandmother fled in the 50s when the
french left because of fear persecution
being affiliated with the french could
you have imagined that vietnamese
culture and cuisine
would have had such a big impact on this
city where you grew up
no
margie's popularity is a prime example
of that impact so what they usually do
is they get some kind of cut of meat
they barbecue it and they'll serve it
with lettuce and a bunch of herbs and
then this is just some grilled shrimp
i don't know how to eat pretty on camera
this is not meant to eat pretty but it
is
delicious as it began to drizzle we made
one last stop at ton den on new orleans
west bank for a traditional dish perfect
for the weather a bowl of pho a soup
named for its flat rice noodles this is
our national dish just a delicate but
very complex broth with noodles and
thinly sliced beef you want something
really flavorful that's stewed that's
cooked down and the french taught us how
to like make a like really nice clear
stock which is what you always want in a
good pho pho shops are so popular here
you see so many different people coming
and enjoying pho and it's i think the
busiest on sunday mornings when
everyone's hungover everyone in new
orleans kind of knows like if you're not
feeling well a bowl of butt is just like
it's
it's the cure-all
but the hangover can wait until tomorrow
for today it's mardi gras here in a city
that's added yet another delicious
culture to its rich recipe
for cbs news jamie wax
new orleans
so i love everything about that story i
thought it was faux now i've learned
it's fun and if you're in new orleans
eating it you can have a barrel of fun
and a bowl of [ __ ] ah i see what you did
there i love it when cultures collide
and we have these hybrid restaurants
listen what we know about new orleans
after looking at that certainly is it's
so much more than beignets although the
beignets are very very cheap you love
you something i really do you just said
beignets about ten times
every affiliate across the whole country
heard about the gays i really do if i
lived in new orleans i'd weigh 300
pounds of food they're so good